I'm at Viet earthquake Observatory in
goating in Germany this is the oldest
working seismic station earthquake
detector in the world but there's also a
more unusual bit of scientific equipment
here a four tons steel ball but can be
raised up 14 meters above the ground and
then dropped because it's a lot easier
to set up and calibrate no earthquake
detector if you can make the ground
shake yourself the equipment we have
here started to work 1903 and it's still
working we had was the one who created
the first real working seismometer these
things record on smoked paper this is
ordinary white paper we take the flame
of a paraffin burner to get soot on to
that paper we think we are the only ones
in the world who are doing that we had
had a theory that seismic waves allow
you to look into the inner of our planet
his assistant
min trop had to prove vhat's theory he
started to calculate and he found out if
he takes a ball of about four tons and
drops it then he is creating a small
earthquake an earthquake big enough to
check the theory of MeV hood the
research is here a century ago could
create a tiny artificial earthquake and
then measure it so what well earth
tremors moved through the ground in two
ways the P waves or primary waves
compress the ground back and forth in
the direction that the wave is traveling
squeezing it together traveling slightly
slower are the S waves the secondary
waves which shear the ground
side-to-side and those waves behave
differently in duration and wavelength
and intensity depending on the ground
they're traveling through so if you're
clever and Minter up was clever then you
could set up seismic detectors all round
an area create a small artificial
earthquake by say dropping a four-ton
steel ball and use the reflections from
within the earth to build up a picture
of what was below without having to dig
this knowledge spread all over the world
min table got an invitation to Mexico
from an oil drilling company they had an
oil field
they asked min table if he could measure
the size of that oil field he said I
don't know we don't have oil fields and
getting him but he accepted the
invitation to Mexico and of course he
did not take the ball with him because
in Mexico he was allowed was he wasn't
allowed here he was allowed to use
dynamite and he measured the size of
this oil field with an incredible
accuracy
he had the not-so-nice nicknamed the
crazy German who was running around with
bodyguards hiding his equipment intense
because our American friends were very
eager to find out how their works
because that was the license to print
money so a hundred years ago with a much
older release mechanism and probably a
lot more effort that steel ball dropped
for the first time on to what was then
pretty much flat ground nowadays there's
much better equipment for figuring out
what's under the Earth's surface but
it's not quite as dramatic it's still
rolling